well thank you very thank you Connor
thank you everybody for coming on such a
miserable miserable cold evening it's
really we can all huddle together for
warmth like penguins and we'll be fine
um I am uh I'm Tim Harford as you heard
uh it is my pleasure to introduce Adam
Grant and what what can I say about Adam
I mean he is one of the the most uh
exciting and most readable thinkers in
the world today um he's also a man who
once had hidden
potential uh he's a was a competitive
diver who was afraid of heights when he
was admitted to University he was asked
to take a writing test and his writing
was so disastrous he was told that he
needed remedial lessons to to improve
prove it uh now of course he's an
enormous success a a professor at Warton
H the author of multiple bestselling
books uh including think again which is
a book I really love including hidden
potential the book we'll be discussing
uh tonight uh presenter of various
podcasts work life uh from Ted New York
Times uh oped writer I could go on and
on and on please don't and but yeah we
should we should probably talk to uh to
Adam about his book I should also say um
I feel like we're friends um even though
this is actually the first time we met
each other was an hour ago uh and I
think that says something about Adam's
charm and his generosity I feel we're in
incredibly safe hands tonight so we
should we should begin by by talking
about a hidden potential it's a I read
this book over Christmas I loved it um
it's just full of notes and scrib
so many fascinating ideas um about
hidden potential about who can be
successful and how to become more
successful um and how to not just to
become more successful but how to
achieve more um in life it even made me
cry uh I am an economist with a heart
made of dollar bills so it's not it's
not easy to make me cry so um we we
should talk Adam and and I'm going to
hopefully we're going to go all over the
shop tonight but
I'm going to start with a fairly basic
question which is you open the book with
a story about uh a school who they get
into chess and competitive chess why did
you start with this story and what does
it teach us about the the thing the
messages you're trying to get across in
the book well I I do want to weigh in on
that but first I have to say that was
the most positive introduction I've ever
heard from a British
person I'm like what what country is
this where are we I I used to live in
Sheffield and no one ever never talked
that way so you used to live in
Sheffield yes I didn't so so I I grew up
in Chesterfield just about 10 miles
south as youone know what were you doing
in Sheffield sorry excuses what were you
doing in Sheffield uh apparently
watching a lot of snooker was was the
takeaway but uh I did a sabatical at The
Institute of work psychology so my wife
and I moved here it was about uh 17
years ago right and had a blast
excellent and did you spend time at The
Crucible watching the snooker or indeed
anything else mostly mostly on TV at
night but uh we spent a lot of time in
the Peak District in the Lake District
so um thank you for adding a little bit
of upbeat
enthusiasm yeah it's to those memories
it's how we yeah it's how we do things
up north uh
okay now where were we chess yeah yeah
let's let's talk about Chess so I I
actually you know I backed into chess uh
I didn't set out to write about it in
the book um I like chess it's a fun game
to play I'm not particularly good at it
but I was um I was reading some research
and I when I read a book um I think as
you do I always start with the the
evidence and then say I need to find a
story and play journalist uh that will
bring the evidence to life yeah and so
the evidence that I was trying to
capture uh showed that if you had an
experienced kindergarten teacher uh you
ended up being more likely to graduate
from college and also you earned more
money in your career it's like wow
kindergarten teachers matter that much
like the person who taught you when when
you were 5 years old if you were lucky
to have somebody who had 20 years of
experience uh that set you up for
success and I I just couldn't believe
that at first and then after I looked
through the the evidence from economists
it was very rigorous and very compelling
and the mechanism stunned me I thought
that the the experienced kindergarten
teachers were great at teaching math and
reading and they' give you a cognitive
Edge but as you know that's not what the
data showed what really mattered was
they taught you character skills they
taught discipline they taught
determination they taught you to be
proactive in seeking new knowledge and
pro-social in sharing your knowledge and
I wanted to write about the importance
of character skills in driving growth
and I was looking for a story and I
spent a good three months spinning my
wheels um uh trying to find is there one
magical kindergarten teacher who has
three students over the course of
decades who have gone on to achieve
extraordinary things and I couldn't find
one and then eventually I gave up and I
said what's the closest thing to a
kindergarten teacher a coach and so I
started searching for coaches of teams
that had unlikely success and I I
stumbled it was literally a Google
search into a story about the Raging
Brooks and I was so moved by them and
their coach I said this this could be
the whole book but at minimum it's got
to be the intro yeah and the Raging
Rooks this is a team of kids who often
never played chess before uh they go to
a rough school they come from a rough
area they have a lot of
disadvantages and you know we don't want
to spoil the story completely but they
ended up they end
up in very very competitive chess
environments playing chess against kids
who have every advantage and every
privilege and and frankly who are better
chess players than them and and how do
they deal with that and and rise to that
challenge and it's all about character
not it's not just about how good you are
at playing chess it turns out
surprisingly so the their Coach Maurice
Maurice Ashley he had uh immigrated to
New York from Jamaica and he wanted to
create opportunity for kids who had been
denied it and he said what I'm going to
do is I'm going to teach you that
mastering the game of of Chess is all
about honing your character skills so
we're going to teach you to have the
discipline to not take the first good
move that you see but actually do the
analysis and look for a better one we're
going to teach you to be proactive in
anticipating your opponent's moves and
trying to see the end game from the
beginning we're also going to teach you
to be pro-social in reviewing every game
you play with your teammates and
coaching each other on how you could
have made better choices and guess what
when you get into a high press moment in
the national championships um no matter
how good you are at chess if you don't
have those character skills you fall
apart um you don't have the discipline
to pause and have patience under
pressure when the clock is ticking um
you haven't necessarily thought far
enough ahead when You' made a move and
somebody's about to Checkmate you and
you feel like you just have to dodge and
you miss the opportunity to go on office
so um I think that that Maurice was an
incredible teacher of character skills
and for me it was a powerful story
because he demonstrated that if you can
get good at teaching and learning the
skills of character at any stage of Life
uh you can actually achieve more than
you thought was possible and more than
other people expected of you and these
are the the so-called soft skills which
I mean this I was blown away when you
revealed what the origin of the of the
phrase soft skills was does anybody know
where soft skills come from as a term
and if you've read the book you can't no
that that doesn't count but thank you
for reading uh so I I I I was really
disappointed to learn this so the origin
of the term soft skills is the US Army
back in the 1960s was trying to classify
a set of skills that they didn't know
how to describe uh and they called them
soft skills they were basically
leadership skills collaboration skills
um character skills uh resilience um
they called them soft because they
didn't involve working with tanks or
guns so there was no metal the hard
skills were the literal weapon skills
and then all the important stuff that
they thought really drove growth and
team success those were soft skills and
they basically ruined our ability to
take soft skills seriously for the next
half century yeah thank you US
Army so I mean the book is is
in large part about soft skills and the
building of these soft skills the
building of these character skills how
to cultivate them in ourselves how to
cultivate them in in other people one of
the things that I think is unusual very
unusual about the book I mean there are
we we're we're blessed it's a golden age
of kind of thoughtful books full of
great stories and interesting research
one of the things that is different
about this one is it so full of
practical
ideas so for example the you talk about
prosociality you have this example in
the book of how
you with your own
students uh you were giving them these
tough tests and these multiple choice
tests and and you said oh um I will give
you in some circumstances you're allowed
to basically say hey instead of using my
answer I'm going to nominate someone
else in the
class and uh and whatever they say you
could give me that the the grade for
that answer and that I think unlocked
something very interesting and and I
don't think it was you weren't intending
to do it right you it was an accident
complete accident so I went into class
one day I had a group of undergrads
mostly 20 and 21 years old and I told
them that the final exam was going to be
extremely challenging because I think
what I teach matters I think
understanding human psychology is
relevant to your success and your
happiness and your relationships with
other people and I want you to know this
material cold so I'm going to give you
not just multiple choice questions I'm
going to give you multiple multi
multiple choice where uh we've got five
answer options and you also have it
could be a and b or a and C or A and D
or a B and C or a and d and they looked
at the sample questions and freaked out
and they said we're just even if we know
the material we're never going to we're
never going to figure this out and I
didn't want to I didn't want to reduce
the challenge level uh but I did want to
reduce their anxiety so I said all right
I'm going to let you pick the hardest
question and write down the name of a
classmate who you think will know the
answer and if they get it right you get
the points
too and all of a sudden they were like
great yes we're all going to memorize
the name of the smartest kid in the
class we're all going to then write it
down and then then we're good and I gave
out the final exam and the class average
went up by I think it was 3% uh with an
identical degree of difficulty from the
previous year's exam and then happened
again the next year and I thought like
well they're just getting the extra
points because they wrote down the name
of someone who knew the answer that they
didn't but actually the gain had nothing
to do with that what happened was and a
group of students explained it to me was
once they needed to know who was the
expert they had to study together
instead of alone and so they started
organizing group study sessions and
class study sessions and then each
student became an expert on a different
segment of the material and then their
job was to summarize it and teach it to
the rest of the class and lo and behold
the students who did the teaching were
actually the ones who learned the most
yeah I mean that's how I forget that's
the coach effect that's the teach the
tutor effect so talk us through this
because I found this very interesting
okay so the the original finding here um
can I just get a show of hands how many
of you are firstborn in your family
oldest child or um or only child okay
technically only child you get to pick
your order you could be first or last um
okay and how many of you are laterborns
you have an older
sibling okay let me apologize in advance
I don't want to offend any of you but
there there is an empirically robust
finding in Psychology that firstborns
score slightly higher on IQ tests than
laterborns I knew
it as a firstborn I was delighted by
this evidence my sister was really
pissed so the question is why and you
all know in birth order it can't be
genetics right there has to be a nurture
component not a nature component um or
maybe something in between which we
probably won't talk about today but one
of the findings is that uh actually the
more younger siblings you have as a
firstborn
uh the more of an IQ boost you get and
it's a very small effect by the way but
it comes from the fact that the older
kid has to teach the younger siblings
and the more time you spend teaching
your young younger siblings the more you
have to retrieve information in your
head which means you remember it better
and the more you have to explain it
which means you understand it better and
so I think this is what was happening
with my students is they were teaching
this material over and over again and
eventually as they talked it through it
clicked and it stuck and by the way
later born you just need to teach other
kids and you're
good three younger sisters uh two
younger step siblings just saying
um so
so where is your British humility
now I mean like SC I'm not I'm not
taking credit for it I'm just saying
like now now I understand that my
Brilliance has nothing to do with me
it's ah you're trying to give credit to
your younger sisters for giving you the
privilege of teaching I understand that
yeah credit for something anyway for
sure um
so so I mentioned the the book has all
these various practical ideas um one of
the things that really grabbed me was
was your description of your process for
getting feedback or actually you said
don't ask for feedback so let's not say
feedback getting information from other
people that will help you perform better
so what what is your basic approach to
to getting useful advice useful feedback
from others talk us through it do you
want the quick uh the quick tip or do
you want the story that leads into the
tip what do you reckon
go yeah all right we're going to do the
quick tip uh no okay so the the story I
guess what what really taught me this
lesson was I was 25 years old uh I just
finished my doctorate and I got an
invitation to teach uh Air Force
Generals in kernel in the US uh I was
supposed to teach a 4-Hour class on
motivation and Leadership and I was
supposed to do it twice uh two different
groups uh one week and then another
group the next week I felt completely
underqualified I felt like a huge
impostor um these uh these Colonels in
generals they had multi-billion pound
budgets they had uh thousands of flying
hours under their belt they had cool
nicknames like out of Top Gun uh they
were called Gunner and Striker and
sandun I was in intimidated out of my
mind but let's uh let's let's be honest
I had never tried to serve my country
before and I felt like they asked I
should I should try to contribute so I
said yes and I showed up and I thought
what I got to do is convince these
people that I know what I'm talking
about so I opened by describing all my
credentials and talking about my
expertise and all the research I'd done
and and then I taught this 4-Hour class
and the feedback afterward was
brutal uh I read the feedback forms and
one comment said uh there was more
knowledge in the audience than on the
podium
facts another had written I gained
nothing from this session but I trust
the instructor got useful
Insight now you all are amused by this
this was not fun for me like my my my
first thought was like like I wonder if
humans can hibernate like bears like how
many months can I can I go to sleep for
until this doesn't hurt Hur
anymore and I had a problem which is I
had committed to teach another session
and I didn't have time to reboot my
material i' had crammed everything I
knew into four hours I also didn't have
um much time uh to to make any real
changes so all I could do was I could
take my critics and try to turn them
into my
coaches and I wasn't sure how to do that
I had these people who were just
trashing my not only my knowledge but
also the way I delivered the
knowledge and I thought all right their
feedback was not helpful instead let me
ask them for advice so I went to a few
of the participants and I said can you
give me one suggestion for what I could
do better next
time and I got a lot of useless tips
like why don't you go run a bunch of
organizations and you know lose all your
hair check now but like you know be
experienced in seasoned before you try
to tell us how to lead I'm like I can't
do anything with that I don't have a
time machine um but I also got a really
useful tip which was uh one person said
well you know we can tell that you're
half our age why don't you call out the
elephant in the
room I thought okay that's something I
can I can control and I can change my
intro so Tim I I showed up the next week
I looked out at the audience and I
thought I have nothing to lose it could
not go worse than it did I I I I picked
one guy in particular I looked at sandun
and I said I said I know what you're
thinking right now I know exactly what's
on your mind what could I possibly learn
from a professor who's 12 years
old sandun was not at all entertained by
that
question uh but another another
participant jumped in and said oh that's
ridiculous you got to be at least
13 and that broke the ice and the whole
room burst out laughing I taught the
same material I had before but the
feedback was completely different
afterward I got comments like although
Junior in experience he dealt with
evidence in an interesting way and the
professors seem to get younger every
year or is it just me getting older and
I like learning about how to motivate
Millennials from someone who almost is
one and it was a great lesson for me to
take myself off a pedestal uh and you
know try to show a little bit of
vulnerability but I think to now answer
your question I think the mistake that
we had made before is when we gave out
the feedback forms when you ask people
for feedback they tell you what you did
wrong or right yesterday
which means you have a bunch of critics
and you have cheerleaders and neither of
those groups is helping you grow um they
might actually demotivate you if they're
critics um and if they're cheerleaders
they might make you complacent what I
wanted were coaches people who saw my
hidden potential and were willing to
help me develop it and it turns out the
research shows that when you ask people
for advice rather than feedback they
give you more constructive tips instead
of Looking Backward they look forward
and they say well here's a specific
thing that I think you could adjust and
so I actually think we should stop
having feedback conversations and start
having advice conversations yeah I think
that's absolutely right i' I've got do I
do I do although if I give you some
advice no I I I have become very
interested in this in this question of
feedback and and how difficult it is to
get useful feedback and I think framing
it as
advice uh works for me and very often I
find I give a lot of talks for example
and you come off stage and the instinct
is you say well you know how was it like
how did I
do and what you really want to be told
is you did great and actually that's
what happens because you step off stage
people because it's hard people know
it's hard everyone's people Pat you on
the backing air you did a great job you
did a great job very very unusual for
someone to say um maybe next time you
could do the following thing and it
would be better and they don't say that
because you didn't ask actually possibly
because you didn't really want to hear
but the the best um feedback I've ever
got is from people who volunteered that
so I once gave a a speech and one of the
senior folk in uh the Ted organization
was in the audience and I came off stage
and a whole bunch of people saying great
job great job and he I could see him
lingering I thought I want to hear what
he has got to say and he he came up and
he
said you um you talked about this uh
this British fighter plane the
Spitfire but a lot of the audience are
international and they wouldn't
necessarily know what a Spitfire is so
next time I think you should include a
photograph of a Spitfire and it was like
it's great it's
specific here's exactly what you need to
do here's why you need to do it and like
and this is why Ted is such a brilliant
Organization for coaching speakers and
presenting speakers so but you you have
this so you're gonna say something well
no I I I think what's interesting here
is and some of you have lived this the
the more senior you get the more success
you achieve the harder it is to get
people to tell you the truth yeah um I I
I've worked with some leaders where I I
kind of imagine that they come into work
in the morning and they say good morning
and a bunch of people are like great
Point um maybe some of you work for
those leaders I hope none of you are
those leaders but uh what one of the
things I've learned is uh so after every
talk I give every event I do I as soon
as I get backstage I ask what's the one
thing I can do better yeah that's my
advice question and sometimes people
don't have notes and I'm so disappointed
yeah often they don't have notes
actually
do not expect to be asked the question
no they don't apparently it's rare but
sometimes I think uh they were just
absorbed or engaged and you know they
weren't really thinking critically about
it but other times they're afraid they
don't want to hurt your your ego they
don't want to damage the relationship
and I ended up studying this a few years
ago and I I found with um constantinos
cerus uh in a series of studies that
criticizing yourself out loud can help
yeah so when when when I get kind of
deer and headlights reactions I have to
say well here are the three things that
I think I did
um I rambled way too long on this
current answer I'm doing it right now um
I uh I feel like I didn't I missed an
opportunity to tailor uh one of the
points to your industry or to the
culture I'm in right now um what do you
think about those things and then what
else did you see and it it's so
interesting to watch people's reactions
when I do that because I'm not just
claiming that I want feedback or
information or advice I'm demonstrating
to them live that I can take it yeah and
that I'm not here to you know to prove
that I'm a great speaker I'm here to
improve my ability as a speaker and uh I
think some I I've gotten this question a
few times when I talk about this
research people are like wait but isn't
it scary to admit the things you screwed
up guess what the people who interact
with you they already know what you're
bad
at you can't hide it from from them you
can't so you might as well get credit
for having the self-awareness to see it
and then the humility and integrity to
admit it out loud yeah I think and I'm
gonna I'm gonna give shorter comments
now where did you want to go with this
you don't have to well okay just do you
think we need to more questions and
shorter answers or are we is it fine as
we
are okay there's the feedback it's
fine don't agree with him just because
Tim lives here and I don't so this is
like a home a home field advantage you
give me a you can give me a short answer
to this one because on the same subject
you specifically say you ask people to
give you a a score out of 10 which I
found counterintuitive but it made sense
when you explained it so why do you do
that I I learned this as a springboard
diver every time I hit the water my
coach would give me a 0 to 10 score and
it was the only thing that helped me
calibrate do I need to make a major
change or a minor change so um actually
before I ask what can I do better I ask
people for the 0 to 10 score and if
somebody says eight I know they really
meant a six and they were being nice um
but you know I'm going to make some some
significant adjustments if somebody says
four I need to I need to go back to the
drawing board and so it's a way to for
me to gauge how big is the comment
you're about to give me yeah what
happens if someone someone says 10 which
I imagine does happen it it does happen
and I tell them I don't accept tens and
uh and then they're they're like well
okay n and a half I'm like great well
what would have made it a 10
like now that would be annoying but okay
um you specifically what would have made
it to 10 you accepting my first answer
but I'm willing to be annoying in
service of being better service of
personal growth that's fair enough so
okay personal
growth so just asking for a friend
so let's let's say that uh there was
like a 50-year-old Economist grew up in
Chesterfield and he uh he had gotten
interested in calisthenics so we kind of
like uh you know those fun you know
those funny sort of gym rings and kind
of like doing stuff on that and so on um
but he wasn't very good at it mainly
because he's a 50-year-old Economist um
and it's kind of it's hard work actually
trying to get better
um give me give him this friend of mine
some some advice based on based on your
research based on the ideas in your book
how how to learn more effectively at
this difficult discipline okay so I have
two questions first number one why like
why are you doing calisthenics and
trying to get better at it yeah it's uh
I want to get fitter stronger I mean my
friend wants to get fitter stronger
maybe look slightly better on the beach
uh also it's it's fun your body is
moving in unusual ways that you've never
you're trying to do things you never
done before that's interesting okay um
nothing up there was nothing rude about
that no nothing you just describe sounds
fun at all but yeah uh okay and then
says says the springboard diver that's
that's different you get to feel like a
bird for half a second okay and then a
dolphin it's fun okay um it's the
transition from the bird to the dolphin
that wores me but fine okay fair enough
uh okay the other question is um where
where are you stagnating what do you not
like what's the specific thing you want
to get better at yeah okay so I'm I need
to go and ask my coach about that um uh
what the it just feels hard it's just
hard you go and you know you I'm uh my
coach is currently in Morocco for you
know reasons so I'm going to the gym by
myself with a spreadsheet do these
exercises by myself it's very easy to
just kind of cheat slack a bit I'm a bit
busy or my back hurts a bit maybe I
won't do the the work um so there's that
kind of there's that barrier to pushing
as hard as you should to get the maximum
benefit got it okay so I I mean Thinking
Out Loud here I I would do bear with us
sorry no I mean I I would do a couple
things the first one I the place i' want
to start is to say why are you so
opposed to the feeling of it being hard
yeah if it feels easy then you're not
challenging yourself it's supposed to be
hard I think um secondly I think this
seems like an opportunity for deliberate
play as opposed to deliberate practice
uh you claimed it was fun but then
you're talking about pushing yourself
through a slog uh that's that's sort of
painful and so well I'll give you my
version of this so um I uh I I run on a
treadmill and the first thing I did to
try to make it fun was uh I I told my
wife to delete shows from the DVR uh if
um if I didn't meet my workout goals
this is fun no but um if I did meet them
then they would stay there and I could
watch them while I run okay and so that
was motivating to say like I really want
to know what happened in um Harland
coin's new Netflix series and uh some of
you are probably watching right now um
fool me once is that what it's called is
anyone watching it yeah loved it anyway
um so that's a reward that's sitting
there that I paired with the activity
that makes it fun for me um number two I
have specific goals um that I'm
competing against myself for and so like
personal bests are really hard what I
can do though is I can improve upon
yesterday and so what I do is I I chart
my progress week by week and I'm like
okay this is a motivating to challenge
now to see if I can be better than I was
last week so have you tried all of this
already no this is all good this is all
good because I feel that I'm just like
I'm just kind of white knuckling it and
going yeah I just yes it should be hard
so it's going to be hard but but it can
be fun as well maybe yeah yeah we'll
find out the uh and you had this idea of
um so there's there's this great chapter
about deliberate play you talk about
Steph Curry's uh training regime um
there's also this idea of inter leaving
which I found interesting oh yes so this
this was counterintuitive to me if you
look at learning research um I always
thought that you should practice the
same skill over and over again in order
to get better at it because you do one
rep and you figure out what your mistake
was and then you make the adjustment and
then you want to see if you've been able
to correct it and then you keep refining
that way psychologists don't find that
um they find that alternating between
different skills actually leads to
deeper learning and faster growth so for
example let's say you're trying to
improve your basketball shot and you
want to become a better painter the
advice is to alternate between those
those two things um go out take you know
five shots and then do a painting and
then come back um and the reason I think
there are actually a few mechanism
mechanisms behind it but the one that I
found most compelling is that when you
put it away for a little while then um
you're actually um you're ingraining it
more when you have to then re rehearse
it as opposed to you can go to autopilot
too quickly if you do them back to back
to back to back and do we do we have the
data on kind of what that period should
be I mean you said five shots and then
go paint I mean is that it or is it like
basketball for a day and then painting
for a day do we or do we not this is the
kind of precision that economists always
want in human
behavior and psychologists cannot
provide y uh I think no I mean a lot of
what I would guess just comes from
here's a particular experiment that
happened to work with a 10-minute
interval on this and then a 10-minute
interval on that I think the best
guideline from the researchers who study
this is when you start to get bored or
when you start to stagnate it's time to
switch yeah yeah so on the subject of
what psychologists can teach us and
stepping away from the book for a moment
because uh we don't want to cover
everything in the book because you all
want to buy the book right because it's
fantastic um can we talk about the the
state of uh organizational psychology
and sometimes called the replication
crisis uh there been various scandals
which we won't go into uh it's all just
a bit too painful um but just this
general feeling Daniel Carman I think
the great no priz winning uh
psychologist put it quite well recently
he said 10 years ago when I read a a
surprising finding that was backed by
the data seemed to be backed by the data
I'd believe it and now when I read a
surprising finding that seems to be
backed by the data my instinct is not to
believe it um because there have been so
many there have been some credible
allegations about and out fraud but also
just a lot
of pretty sloppy research a lot of stuff
that turned out not to stand up so what
is your feeling about this field that
you you you're in the middle of now so
my job is not to have feelings about the
field it's to follow the evidence and I
think there are a couple things I've
learned from the evidence the first one
is uh look science evolves and our
methods should get rigorous over time so
you know a bunch of my ear early studies
were done with smaller samples than I
would use today um and part of that was
a problem of access and part of that was
um some flaw assumptions about
statistical power that hadn't been um
you know sort of made as transparent um
and clear as they are now um and so I
think this is science progressing is the
first thing I would say second thing I
would say is um I think that
psychologists have taken the brunt of
this when all kinds of fields are
struggling with replication um there's a
team led by Brian nosik that uh famously
they tried to replicate over 200 papers
in Psychology and they found about half
of the findings
replicated well we have to ask a
question about what is the ideal
replication r i don't expect every
finding to replicate sometimes you have
different people in your studies
sometimes changes over time or across
cultures or contexts really matter um
and sometimes uh you know you you just
you happen to get support for something
that's relatively rare and the outlier
effect um was there and then you run a
larger version of the study and it
wasn't and we don't want a 100%
replication rate um because then we're
not learning we're not testing
surprising ideas ever uh we're just
confirming our intuition
um so Brian's team recently uh they did
replications in cancer biology research
and found failed replications over
40% and so even the hard Sciences have
this problem and there are all kinds of
reasons why you know human bodies would
respond differently to different drugs
at different times um so I think we need
to we need to temper our expectations of
science we want science to get better um
but I think what we want to know is that
probabilistically when you do a series
of studies um that's more likely to
appro oximate the truth than whatever
your intuition is and I guess the other
thing I would say about this is I had a
debate with Danny Conan about this um we
did a rethinking podcast a couple years
ago and I was troubled by his statement
that he doesn't believe a
counterintuitive finding Danny
introduced us in part to confirmation
bias yeah right the problem that we all
like to support the hypotheses we
believe and reject the ones that don't
match our assumptions and motivations
and so if you're going to then knee-jerk
reject a hypothesis because it doesn't
sound true to you you're being a bad
scientist and you know you don't want to
have that debate with a Nobel laurate
because you're not going to win and
Danny convinced me that my thinking
about this was incomplete and that
there's a difference between what I've
now come to think of as um extremely
counterintuitive findings and
non-intuitive findings um I think there
are a lot of cute findings in Psychology
where there's like a tiny thing you do
and then it changes your life like we
should be skeptical about that that is
counterintuitive it's the opposite of
what is likely to be true non-intuitive
is what much more of what we were
talking about earlier I read the study I
never would have thought of that and
then as we unpack the mechanisms and
look at the data that makes sense to me
now and I think that that's something we
should still aspire to
do